foreign
hey there I'm George camel co-host of
the Ramsey Show and we are back with
another exciting round of the best of
the Ramsay show and this one is all
about the wild world of cryptocurrency
what is it should you invest in it and
will it make you a millionaire I know
you want to know so check out this
episode
Washington Post is reporting that
Fidelity Investments with its quarterly
retirement analysis has discovered the
same thing that we already knew from the
Ramsey study of millionaires done a few
years back the largest study of
millionaire has ever done the title is
of the article is move over crypto a
record number of workers are becoming
millionaires with their boring 401ks and
IRAs I love to hear this news the more
boring the more excited I get as an
actual investment strategy so here's
what it says meet the newly minted
millionaires next door they didn't put
all their money into Microsoft type
stock that made them Rich they didn't
take a chance on speculating in crypto
with its crazy volatility or start a
business that they sold to some
billionaire no these are government
workers civil servants Educators
military folks managers co-workers
clocking in just like you and many never
earn six-figure salaries which we found
in our millionaire study one-third never
had a six-figure household income in a
single working year and so in its
quarterly retirement analysis Fidelity
reported that the number of IRAs and
401K millionaires hit an all-time high
that's impressive there it is and not
shocking 401K millionaires by
translation they had over a million
dollars in their 401K they may or may
not be actual millionaires depending on
how much debt they have but uh because
you're you're an actual millionaire is
what you own minus what you owe is your
net worth your assets monitor
liabilities but assuming that they don't
have a bunch of other debt running
around they've got over a million in
their 401K they very likely are
millionaires and that's what we found we
found that the typical millionaire uh it
took them 12 to 15 years to get there
uh 89 did not inherit the money that
made them a millionaire
did not 9 out of ten did not that's
actual facts not your broke
brother-in-law who votes left Wing's
opinion
this is actual facts by actual airtight
research okay so 89 did not inherit the
money that made them a millionaire and
we can actually prove that with the
largest study of millionaires ever done
now having said that then we say take
twice the average is 12 to 15 years to
get there we had two primary components
to their net worth that caused them to
get their first one to five million
dollars of net worth one of those was a
paid for home which we found that the
average millionaire pays off their home
in 11 years and the other is their
retirement account and so when you add
those things together when you get a
paid for home and you've invested 15 of
your household income into 401ks and
IRAs it's amazing how quickly you get
there in the span of your lifetime it's
a blip and 79 of millionaires in our
research reach millionaire status
through their employer-sponsored
retirement plans so this is not a theory
it's uh pretty simple guys pretty simple
uh and it is kind of like the uh like
the article says it's a bit boring
there's really nothing uh nothing you
get to brag about there's no Adrenaline
Rush yeah you're bright you know you're
playing golf or you're fishing with your
buddies you don't get to brag and say
you did something really brilliant all
you did was just steadily invest and pay
off your house
bending then I can't watch crypto over
the weekend 24 7 go up and down up and
down which Bitcoin just had another cry
a crash no I know I'm starting to hurt
your feelings Dave oh I hate it when I'm
right do you not really that was sarcasm
I sensed a little bit of that I actually
don't want anybody to lose money no I'm
not wishing for someone to get hurt
that's not that is the truth but it's
the crypto Bros who think Dave's out of
touch and they have been wearing me out
too so giving me a hard time like I'm an
idiot all over social media because you
know once you join the crypto bandwagon
you're like oh yeah you know it's just
it's like you've we talked about this at
The Building Wealth event Dave the
people who are into crypto are really
into crypto they're obsessed they're
trying to sell all their buddies on
crypto and so we came to the conclusion
that cryptocurrency is just Mary Kay for
young men but you don't get the pink
Cadillac that's upsetting no pink
Cadillac maybe in the metaverse they
have a digital version a virtual you can
get an nft of a Cadillac yeah and get a
picture of you don't really have a
Cadillac well it's a virtual I don't
know what you don't really have one I'm
just saying virtual means not really the
next thing Dave this is if I virtually
send my wife flowers on the anniversary
I don't get anything I'm just saying
she's not gonna like this it's not going
to be a happy day at Ramsay okay I've
virtually sent you flowers darling that
means I almost did it yeah I think the
next trend is going to be nft timeshares
it's a sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership
in the metaverse you buy the timeshare
so we can both live next to Snoop Dogg
for one weekend at a time
this is not a far future Dave I think
I'm a I'm a fortune teller oh this is a
redundancy redundancy Department
we're losing our minds oh we're gonna
get
and nft timeshare a sense of ownership
of a sense of ownership that's how that
works uh that is what the timeshare
people tell you you have a sense of
ownership which means you don't really
have ownership but you kind of can get a
whiff of it yes a whiff I like that
whiff
oh man
this is the culture oh this is what
we're up against Dave Lord Jesus help us
oh we're going to do a nft timeshare
next door to Snoop Dogg I lose brain
cells every time I read headlines like
that well if you were next door to Snoop
Dogg you might be true
I'm gonna google that can I get virtual
second hand
that is a Google search waiting to
happen
oh what a time to be alive did you ever
think in your lifetime this would be a
reality because you've seen a lot of
stupid stuff in your day over 30 years
but it's getting out of control even for
you hey man I I mean no no I didn't have
any idea this is um
I I I actually didn't think the internet
was gonna work you're one of those you
went oh this is a fad it's like you want
to spend five thousand dollars and build
a website what this is when it was first
starting you know with dial up all right
14-4 hook up right
[Laughter]
I remember those days I wore out those
AOL free trials hey Dave you got that
internet
yeah yeah I got that internet and you
had to either use the phone or use the
internet see I'm not that exactly that
young like your facts yeah yeah you
could fax stuff I walked up or there was
email
yeah man when I got in the real estate
business in 1978 we had these things
called facts machines we were members of
e r a electronic Realty Associates yeah
we would send over this Magic Machine
black and white pictures of a listing in
another city
and it would print off took it about
four minutes to print one page and uh it
was an electronic people were buying
real estate based off of that no they
would they would agree to come look at
that piece of real estate with you they
did they were not dumb enough to buy it
off of that that's what's happened dumb
enough to buy it off of that happened
later
and they're coming from other cities
where there's no desperate to buy a
house I haven't even seen it I'll buy it
I'll buy it side unseen no inspection no
appraisal don't care 100 000 over asking
yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm just in a
bidding war we've lost our minds
uh yeah should they teach critical
thinking still in school is that there's
no class on that right no we don't teach
thinking anywhere in the in the United
States it's we don't think anymore
uh so we used to have like arguments and
debates because we didn't have Google to
solve it you can't have a good fight now
because somebody Google's the answer
it's me he's talking about me you and
Rachel are fighting and I got guys it
was 2018. we were having fun arguing
why'd you have to go and ruin it because
Rachel and I do have fun arguing so if
you want to be a newly minted
millionaire according to this article it
is backing up the details that are in
the book baby steps Millionaires and in
the study that is outlined in the back
of the book baby steps millionaires now
if you want to be a billionaire it's a
different formula
you will not become a billionaire with
your 401k
it's mathematically impossible but a
billion is one thousand million
that's a lot of millions so just in case
you were wondering your one thousandth
of a billionaire
when you're a millionaire wow you're
just a peon you're not even close at
that point yeah you're just a pee on it
but you can have a great life as a
millionaire you don't need to be a
billionaire that's a greater life than
if you don't
there it is perspective that's what we
needed there we go thank you for using
your critical thinking skills you still
have a few brain cells left Dave turns
out I'm I'm worried about
this uh sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership next to Snoop Dogg with
secondhand virtual smoke I'm just
worried about this hole this whole line
of thinking George has got me upset well
the only way to make money there is if
you're the one selling it so get to
selling some nfts Dave
um I'm gonna have to hard pass hard pass
Michael starts off this hour in Dayton
Ohio hey Michael how are you
hey Dave how's it going it's an honor to
speak with you and Ken you too sir
what's up
hey so I've been looking a lot at uh
cryptocurrency and I know you guys are a
little against it the it's pretty
hostile in that environment uh I have
about 3 800 saved up from uh working my
job and I just want to know what are the
best investments to really look at and
uh where to go about it
um hostile what do you mean hostile
well hostel where it the validity of it
were the volatility
yes oh yeah definitely okay
well I mean you you have to set your
investment goals with what you believe
is your is your best path to becoming
wealthy otherwise you wouldn't do the
investment right
and so um how old are you
I am 24. okay all right
so when I was 24 I made a lot of
mistakes buying things that I thought
would make me wealthy
quickly and easily I bought a lot of
nothing down real estate I went broke as
a result
I uh I bought gold Futures once a buddy
of mine had a stock broker Ken that a
friend of his it was a gold guy
and he had he had the ticket he had it
figured out he had the formula and uh he
had hit uh buying on the way a future
works you purchase it at a price and if
it goes under that if the if the price
is under that when you get to that date
you get zero if you go if it's over that
then you get a multiple of what you've
put in and so um I bought a future I put
five thousand dollars in that I didn't
really have that's about all I had put
the whole five thousand dollars in
because this guy had hit uh he had hit
14 times in a row on his prediction wow
I mean he was amazing he was like a gold
Savant he had it all figured out I mean
14 times she had hit and the Future made
and so the rate we went in at I put five
thousand dollars in and it was a 10x if
it hit I was gonna make 50 Grand
it was his 15th tribe and we all know
where I'm going with this right oh yeah
you can you can see where the story's
going you know he missed on that try and
my my my little bitty five thousand
dollar net worth was just evaporated
based on my attempt to make 50 000 in 90
days off of 5 000.
um and uh you know bitcoin's hot you're
crypto's hot a lot of people making a
lot of money on it right now it is as
you said Michael very very volatile and
so it falls for me an old guy Under The
Heading of getting rich quick and I have
not found many people that get rich
quick and so I
and I don't like losing money I mean I I
just telling that story from 25 35 years
ago makes my stomach yeah I would think
so I I work too hard for the money that
we get and that we get to keep after the
government takes their share and so I
don't like losing it so Michael you can
certainly do what you want to do but you
called here uh we do not tell people to
invest in highly volatile uh
unpredictable
Investments and currencies of any kind
fall in that category Bitcoin would be
the most volatile among those uh crypto
would be the most volatile among those
and statistically
um you're going to probably get your uh
you know you you might get it I mean the
GameStop thing when the kids were around
the GameStop thing off of Reddit that
was extraordinary and they made you know
one guy called here he put in 3 500
bucks and he made 50 Grand his hit I
mean he was playing he was running
running the short on that thing and uh
you know with those guys they took them
to task he took him to Woodshed it was
interesting to watch from the outside
but I've I've also got a friend that's
invested in six restaurants and I I go
over there and eat
yeah I didn't invest in any of them
that's right and I like the people that
run them but I you know you know what
the failure rate on restaurants is it's
like almost all of them yeah yes you
know they just don't make it and so uh
but he's in he's an investor so he wants
to do that and that's fine I don't I he
called me said you want to put money in
this restaurant I'll go over and eat
I will invest in your food yes yeah well
it's really true the way you teach
investing and the way I live and the way
you live that's right and that's how you
based it there is risk involved of
course but when you're talking about
Bitcoin or really volatile stocks like
this it is I think it's no different
than gambling I'm not trying to be cute
with the words but there's investing
which is I'm going to invest if you
think about the way that word is then
you talk about this kind of stuff and it
is a form of gambling it really is
you're going all right I'm gonna put it
in and hope that it keeps going up but
this stuff could drop just like this out
of nowhere at a minimum it's speculating
not investing that's what gambling might
be on one side and speculation yeah
that's a bit of a strong statement
investing investing might be but that's
what investing investing implies the
tortoise yes speculating implies the
hair yes that's right gambling is the uh
possum in the middle of the road okay
but yeah that's what it feels like
emotionally to me it really does like if
I ever invest in Bitcoin I'd be a I'd
just be I think a better shot at Bitcoin
than you do the lotto so that's all I'm
saying that is fair but both of them are
dumb ideas in my mind and I and I didn't
put any money in either one of them by
the way I've never bought a scratch-off
ticket in my entire life Dave you're no
fun no I just don't like giving my money
away
I can drive if I'm gonna have fun that
way I'm gonna roll down the window with
100 bills out cause a traffic jam you
know we're going down the interstate
that's more fun yeah well you're too
competitive you want to have a shot at
making some money not just I'm gonna
throw it in the air and to see what
happens and you know of course everybody
that's a Bitcoin genius right now thinks
Dave Ramsey's out of touch Boomer which
is probably true but I'm also uh worth
several hundred million dollars so let's
go figure that out but um yeah I'd say
look at the scoreboard take Dave on all
you want to but the scoreboard is a
scoreboard and it does come down to the
your risk tolerance what do you well not
just risk tolerance what is your goal
and what do the data points tell you so
I mean I've had people call the show
investing in Beanie Babies
really uh you remember when beanie
babies were crazy I was a kid I remember
my grandmother a lot of people invested
they were like they were like a such a
hot commodity people were investing in
the calling calling them as a
collectible calling in here saying I put
my kids college fund in Beanie Babies I
did that actually happened for me that's
right up there with Bitcoin yeah I mean
you know I got a lot but I did buy baby
the differences I did by beanie babies
as a gift [ __ ] no Sharon Sharon got it
not not as an investment but Sharon was
collecting them as a hobby and okay
that's good now the grandbabies and the
[ __ ] suit play with them but they uh
that's all they're good for but you know
the thing is Michael you can invest in
whatever you want but the data points
tell us that people who do get rich
quick don't
that's the bottom line
out of studying 10 000 millionaires the
number of them that got rich quick is
very very very small Chris is in New
York City hey Chris how can we help
hey Dave again uh great to be on the
show thanks how can we help yeah um uh
real quick I just want to give a shout
out to my girlfriend Maria Jose she told
me to call in um the reason I'm calling
is because I've got a lot of friends who
are buying into cryptocurrency and you
know my investments are all in mutual
funds like you recommend
um and I'm hearing about you know
Bitcoin dog or Dodge Coin and all these
other things and I I just wanted your
thoughts on how to respond when people
try to pressure you to invest into this
stuff and maybe even get your thoughts
on cryptocurrency in general
okay
I wouldn't do it why
because I think it's still very
speculative we've already seen big highs
and big lows and I think it's still
rocking I do think that crypto is coming
and to stay I think right now it's a lot
of speculation and until it gets adopted
and we start seeing businesses move that
way I'd I'd stay on the sidelines and
it's not a part of our investment
strategy at Ramsey Solutions either so
there's that too which Dave you're far
more versed in that way it's had an
incredible year yeah people made a lot
of money out this year without a doubt
no question about that
um but they make a lot of money on
cocaine too
and they make a lot of money on uh you
know playing Futures and they make a lot
of money at the blackjack table and they
make a lot of money betting football but
these are not investment strategies
that's correct these are these are
things that you can jump into or jump
out of that are Uber unbelievable high
risk and so the problem is is that
people don't perceive the risk in
Bitcoin and it's there it's it's a it's
a it's not it's not fully adopted they
might a lot of money this year made a
lot of money in Gold a few years ago too
and tell people not to buy gold and all
the gold bugs are going Dave Ramsey's an
idiot he doesn't understand now Dave
Ramsey completely understands
so George not only has uh Bitcoin
dropped what 60 something percent now
since September big crash
um that's not six that's 60 percent
ouch that means you turned 100 000 into
40
uh but now we're seeing that a billion
dollars has been lost in crypto scams
according to the Federal Trade
Commission this is wild cryptocurrency
scammers have stolen over one billion
dollars from forty six thousand people
since the start of 2021 a new Federal
Trade Commission report says FTC rang
the alarm bells on Friday saying crypto
related crimes amount to about one out
of every four dollars reported lost to
fraud more than any other payment method
the meeting individual reported loss was
twenty six hundred dollars this is wild
um
crypto scams are becoming increasingly
popular shooting up 60 times higher than
in 2028 nearly half of those who
reported losing money to a crypto scam
in 2021 says they were lured in through
an online post or a social media message
so how are they getting scammed you know
well on Facebook and Instagram they lure
you in with you know they get you to
click the link go to a website and
there's been a lot of actual space scam
accounts impersonating me trying to
message people about crypto and the
people know it's spam and scams once
they go George is telling me to invest
in crypto I know this is a scam so they
report it and they let me know I think
Dave Ramsey telling you get a credit
card exactly not a great move to the
scammers out there and so that's what's
happening and so people get lured in and
they go well this seems you know this
seems like a good deal this seems like
I'm gonna win big on this thing so they
click it and they give them access to
their crypto wallets and all kinds of
things and what are they what are they
what are they why would what are they
buying I mean what's the scam what are
the what's the pitch I have no idea what
there's all kinds of different ones out
there across the board I don't know they
have any details uh here in both cases
scam Gamers promise substantial returns
to their investors but instead pocketed
the money into their own crypto wallets
so they're promising you hey give us the
money we're going to give you an amazing
return on your money into this new
crypto coin and all of a sudden those
returns disappear and they pocket the
money instead
and this is happening all over in
February a Federal grand jury in San
Diego indicted the founder of bit
connect
for allegedly orchestrating a 2.4
billion dollar Global Ponzi scheme
Founders accused of misleading investors
about the cryptocurrencies lending
program claiming company prop companies
proprietary technology would bring
substantive returns to investors by
tracking cryptocurrency exchange markets
so they all come down to this false
promises of easy money paired with
people's limited crypto understanding
and experience so no one truly
understands it and they go
you're saying someone who bought crypto
would fall for false promises of easy
money I just read the article I can't
believe that don't come at me in the
comment section
that's the truth
it's so new it's so volatile the
technology is there and so people are
going well this is my chance kind of my
point is is the very person who buys
crypto to start with
uh is looking for a Cutting Edge easy uh
sophisticated technologically
uh easy money uh and so when someone
presents them with another Cutting Edge
sophisticated thing then they're more
likely to fall for that than the average
Joe because they already are biting it
they're already chewing on that hook
they're trying to get it on the ground
floor of the next thing they're trying
to choose the winning coins yeah in
other words the scammers are taking them
through the same
psychological door that they went
through to buy Bitcoin in the first
place and then they get scammed so
they're more susceptible
to scams and it's not it's all
unregulated so you're not protected
there's no FDIC here going hey we'll
cover your money and so you just lose
this money
that's it
it's not hard to steal people's crypto
man
we've come a long way since the Nigerian
prince this is the modern day version
at least I got a nice nicely worded
email from the Nigerian prince I
remember getting uh copies on a bad copy
machine by snail mail from the Nigerian
prince wow that took effort yeah they
and well it had my name personalized
across the top of this Mo of this copy
that had been made like eight thousand
times so it had the little lines of
stuff on it because you could tell it
was like it was like a mimeograph
machine or something like that yeah I'm
old enough I used to get those from the
Nigerian prince I kind of missed those
days simpler times in the scamming World
simpler times man what was the one that
wasn't the Spanish Flu it was the
Spanish lottery or something that ran
through Canada really it was another one
you know that was a one that was about
30 years of doing this you've seen lots
of scams yeah
so uh Glenn freyshi who wrote the book
con man or Saint we talk about this in
the Building Wealth live event
um he he um was claiming he might be a
saint but he wrote the book from prison
so I'm suspecting he was wrong
um that he was probably come and he ran
he ran a Ponzi scheme a true pyramid
scheme and got put in jail for it in the
70s and um but he he was a he was a
world-class con man
and uh he said one of the quotes I read
that book you know when I was a teenager
I don't know how I ended up with it but
um uh
the quote I remember from the book more
than anything else I went and pulled it
out for this event that we're doing that
he said you can con someone of any
intellect any level of Education
if you can activate greed or fear
and um and they also they um
and really in a sense the part of the
greed one is pride
you know like you're in on something the
cool kids are in on it nobody except the
cool kids are in on it and you're one of
the cool kids you know you're not you
know you know people who aren't
sophisticated don't understand Bitcoin
and uh you're obviously sophisticated
because you understand Bitcoin and so
you're in Bitcoin and since you're in
Bitcoin we're going to give you this
other opportunity here and a billion
dollars in scam
oh not to mention how many billions is
it over a trillion now in Lost value
that it went down 60 yeah
so the total market value loss of
Bitcoin I I read it it was an
astronomical number it's like a trillion
dollars or something when it went from
you know when it's gone down 60 percent
that means people had value at some
point that hypothetically they could
have cashed in somewhere and didn't
and so they have now ridden this thing
to the bottom yeah we're seeing some
really sad stories of how much people
are losing in this who they had a
million dollars in it and now they have
nothing I was just reading a
heartbreaking story about one guy who's
honest enough to share his losses which
is pretty rare most of them only brag
about the wins well it's like a bad golf
game or a fisherman that's right which
you never had a bad golf game so you
don't have to worry about that I've
never caught a fish either never
but it's pretty wild stuff so I mean you
know we talk about buyer beware but with
crypto it's a whole other animal because
there's a whole technological piece that
most people don't understand and I think
I'm a pretty smart guy and the more I
look into crypto the more confusing it
gets
and I think they did that on purpose no
no that's like whole life it's really
complicated on purpose because well you
don't have to worry about it it gets
complicated just trust me give me the
premiums I'll give you the returns to me
trust me
trust me
yeah oh man this is trying to find out
what this thing has done let's see here
in one year
the losses yeah
yeah it's astronomical
this is wrong okay I was trying to pull
it up on a website while I'm on the air
that's a dumb thing to do I'll tell you
that this guy he reportedly uh he has a
whole thread on Twitter how I went from
a crypto millionaire to broke in six
months due to leverage a gambling
addiction and an accelerating negative
spiral and he goes through in the thread
about every single piece of the puzzle
that caused him to lose this million
dollars and now he's got nothing
he said he could have retired he could
have done a lot of things with that
money and that was a lot of regret
it's sad we like to make fun of crypto
but I don't like anyone losing a lot of
money that breaks my heart I won't be
hurt yeah but I am
um more than a little bit
um as much criticism as we took for over
from the crypto that's true from the
crypto kids a little Vindication yeah
well folks that's it for the best of the
Ramsey show this season as Boyz II Men
once said it's the end of the road I
hope you enjoyed it hope you had a good
time be sure to check back soon for a
new season and in the meantime you can
check out episodes of the Ramsay show
Daily on Radio podcast and YouTube we'll
see you soon